je suis bien préparé
je rappelle d'ailleurs que c'est le
parti communiste
moi même qui avait demandé lors de ma
dernière mission d'un égal avec chirac
qu'enfin on organise à la télévision un
débat sur le système socialiste mondiale
le socialisme échec ou réussite c'est le
thème par conséquent tenant compte que
nous avions demandé ce débat tenant
compte de l'importance de la question
vous comprendrez sans peine que je me
sois très soigneusement préparé pour
combattre les contre vérités la
désinformation au sujet ce qu'est le
socialisme mondial
je ne connais pas personnellement
monsieur peyrefitte genoux des valois ne
veut pas dévoiler devant vous
naturellement comment j'ai préparé mes
attaques
ce que je sais c'est que je vais avoir
devant moi le représentant des forces
réactionnaires qui sont résolument
opposés au socialisme
par conséquent le débat va se situer
entre un homme qui est un représentant
du capitalisme un défenseur du
capitalisme d'un système d'oppression
des travailleurs et des masses
populaires et moi qui va défendre le
système socialiste
ce qui ne veut pas dire que je vais
défendre le socialisme tel qu'il existe
dans tel ou tel pays
il est évident et je l'expliquerai que
la construction de la société socialiste
en france devra soigneusement tenir
compte des conditions particularité
variations nationale est ce que vous ne
craignez pas d'apparaître en participant
à cette émission comme une sorte de
champion de l'anti soviétisme côté il
faut pas confondre anticommunisme et
anti soviétique anticommuniste nous le
sommes et nous ne voyons pas pourquoi
nous n'aurions pas le droit de l'être
puisque les communistes sont anti
gaulliste comme ils sont anti libéraux
ils sont contre notre système de vie et
notre système de pensée et contre notre
type de civilisation
alors je vois pas pourquoi nous
n'aurions pas le droit de les combattre
mais en range
la nulle anti soviétisme en vérité je
n'aurais jamais pris l'initiative d'une
émission comme celle là c'est le parti
communiste qui réclament depuis un an à
cor et à cri une émission pour faire le
bilan des pays communistes et d'ailleurs
depuis 50 ans il nous représente les
pays communistes comme le modèle de
société qu'il faudrait limiter chez nous
alors il faut bien que nous nous
défendions en face de cela il a là aucun
anti soviétique
comment vous êtes vous préparé pour
cette émission on vous savez c'est comme
disait ce peintre à propos de son
tableau il m'a pris deux heures et toute
ma vie la préparation direct a été assez
rapide
sauf que la préparation du film m'a pris
beaucoup de temps mais la préparation
lointaine cela représente 25 ans de
réflexion et d'expériences sur les
systèmes de sociétés qui sont proposées
aux hommes d'aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
le problème majeur de notre temps